[Music]
in shitty dad news submitted by
black/pink
a wife says she has to turn off the
Wi-Fi when her husband goes to the
toilet because he's jacking off oh no
because he thinks her yeah reading
emails on there well he's oh that's not
fair to some people's poops have a
half-time like mine does I mean he can't
just be like no cause I know he waits
it'll be like like two logs come out
your intestines are just kinda chillin
and it's just a period of gas that's the
halftime show like two one or two more
lines come out and do you do a postgame
press conference you have a review yelp
site for your [ __ ] day it cleans the
court oh it's a Sam be no Sam beetle is
that you don't know that you think that
cleans ice yeah you could have called it
anything what yeah it was the you know
ice rinks and hockey and ah yeah that's
a cool thing all right anyway so this is
posted on subreddit on the subreddit a
might be [ __ ] usually you are well
we'll find out so this one says my
husband and I are the parents of twins
who are less than a year old oh there it
is there it is yeah I get it
Heidi yeah anytime I wear a diaper then
mm-hmm take care of the fun kids anytime
my husband should be doing something
with the children parentheses it's his
turn for a diaper a bottle or even just
soothing a fussy newborn he always goes
to the bathroom first is my guy where is
he that smart no he's an idiot we are
both on maternity slash paternity leave
Wow my husband is on medication that
makes him spend a lot of time in the
bathroom about an hour after a meal it's
an option he has that he's been on on
and off several times over the past year
he is never on it for
more than a few weeks and it does not
affect him at all the time but he always
claims that that is why he is in the
bathroom stop God you know you gotta try
you gotta try has some evidence to back
it up true so then she makes me [ __ ]
poop I can't help it what can I do I
gotta shave my face I gotta poop mmm
so he writes I did ask the doctor didn't
say it was impossible but highly
unlikely the doc wanted him to come in
for a checkup
if this was the case and the husband
said oh it's not that bad in refused me
this is every man in the world so then
she continued I would rather let him use
the restroom first then have to put down
a baby mid test but over the past couple
months he has been spending more and
more time in there he always takes his
phone he's always watching YouTube his
average session is 25 minutes in there
often longer rarely shorter it's the
most frustrating when it comes time to
feed them because one of the twins needs
to be held specifically for health
reasons so I cannot double me because we
will get up I will warm up bottles
change one baby bump get the first one
fed burped and laid down in their crib
get the other baby change and be
settling down to feed baby number two
before he can be bothered to emerge and
figure out why one child has been
screaming because they had to watch
their sibling eat and I are I and then
we went and then the other
when cry when they don't get to cuddle
at all because I have to immediately set
them down to feed the hysterical saw
hysterically sobbing child she had two
arms on she two arms come on man
yesterday was a week and a half since I
started truly keeping track and he only
twice in ten days not ditched me to go
camp out in the bathroom and let me
finish 80% of the childcare today I say
brother-in-law's like this yes yes
that's someone we actually know damn
today I started a new role if he was in
the bathroom for more than 10 minutes I
flipped the Wi-Fi off he has not spent
more than 15 minutes in the bathroom at
a stretch today but is extreme
we upset I feel like the fact that
without the Wi-Fi his uncontrollable
uncontrollable to toilet issue cleared
up rather quickly
he doesn't have three G's what's going
on maybe the area sucks
I can't wait to be off Wi-Fi I like that
this story shuts down all feminists that
think girls don't need guys cuz
obviously she needs guys oh she has twin
babies she needs guys arguing I just
presented the two opposing parties to
each other have them sure we all bonus
thought that children didn't need
fathers that's true true that's what
they say you know what you know what I
got a solution make the kid more
entertaining than YouTube and then maybe
you won't need to be on YouTube well I
mean it's your genetics making it not
more fun home they didn't raise them
very fun what if he's on YouTube
watching a Family Channel and there's a
kid that he likes watching more than
they're like take it so fun but he feels
I am being unreasonable and I need to
make sure sleep and I need to make sure
sleep deprivation isn't making me an
[ __ ] so then she says edit to answer
questions that people have been asking
yes I have talked to him about this ten
days ago we had a conversation about the
situation and he denied how long he's
been spending in the bathroom this
conversation is also where the one where
I proposed he see a doctor no he does
not know about mobile hotspots he's
never heard of them he has no idea they
exist never LTE yeah yes he has downtime
he spends a good deal about a good deal
of time working on his car and plays
Diablo about eight hours straight every
day
food banks for paternal leave gets it
and uses it to play Diablo that's [ __ ]
shaky most of his time on the other side
of the house on his PC in the office
he's still on Diablo and then at night
he tries to go to talk about a we're
free xbox bat to this guy he's like my
[ __ ] wife cheated on me why would she
do that he's like honey there's a
there's an Xbox where when you hit the
power button it makes the Taco Bell
chime so the internet decided she is not
the [ __ ] no she's not she left out
the Diablo part what the [ __ ] do we like
this guy now you would he's funny but he
can't figure oh my god she's his data in
the best streaming like I don't have
enough data my plan just Larry he's
played an old game it's very old game so
he doesn't exactly need hmm you know to
know at the most critical moment where
she needs himself this baby
she should test him to oh the baby's
gotta eat and if he goes to the bathroom
then she'll know true I would lock all
the [ __ ] toilet all the bathrooms in
there record baby sounds reported
screaming so that it sounds like the
kids screaming and they turn it off and
he comes out and then when the kid
actually screams it's like she should
yeah we have like some of the comments
here is not the [ __ ]
what kind of a man [ __ ] around on the
internet while his baby screams in
Christ what is like fixing his car
videos twins that are dying
that's [ __ ] girls in here too that
they were like man this sounds like my
ex-husband he used to go he would lock
himself in the bathroom to watch porn
why would care for our toddler and our
newborn Hey he's like why can't I have
my sexy girlfriend back my sexy wife
before she was a ball that came in her
and what a kid you girlfriend
now she's a dumb mom she's all old she's
a mom he's like that's okay I could pick
this hot chick to play as in Diablo yeah
so then someone else said yep my ex did
the same thing the longest was three
hours three freakin hours in the
bathroom he had no medical condition
just acute selfishness a woman at my
postnatal depression group recommended I
do this and funnily enough he the moment
I'd flipped the switch on the Wi-Fi I'd
hear the toilet flushing he come down to
check if the Wi-Fi goes back up he's
ribbon cables open take a seat like
ceiling units down he's like what the
[ __ ] happened in here yeah we got a lot
of people in these comments are like
hugs yeah there's a side of me inside
that kind of understands where it comes
from
oh just the way I was raised about I
wasn't raised on a lot of kids
so when baby issues pop up my first
instinct is what the [ __ ] no no I can
totally go with if my initial gut is
what the [ __ ] same who are the girls we
both should have been like [ __ ] it who
are the girls around you bark with me
grandma and your wife yes oh yeah we're
gonna do the other thing but they just
let me that's all I want to they're like
oh yeah understand what's happening like
I'm still there dude we hear the child
crying what are you talking about yep I
don't know why it's crying you're like
he's hungry and I'm like he's hungry
yeah cuz I'm just like it's like you're
here to go like that but I bet about a
lot of music
you've actually a [ __ ] phenomenal
partner there the support i'm darren
support but then Tyco big-time just like
this
you know but I got three balls one on
rolled under the couch we have to go get
that one I'm like do you know that are
you a funny guy or are you a good father
I feel like I'm a good dad you got funny
but on the inside I know where these
balls come from because Oh what if it
was twins like me both of you
oh this guy's a dick I don't want that
[Laughter]
oh yeah just you know yeah I was like he
just changed Leia's diaper put her down
because I called you'd get the chill a
little bit changed a new guy's diaper
Leah's hungry goes back and it's just
like this constant like on my own I
heard that going from one kids to two
kids is the hardest but if you can
handle two if you get a good system now
and then you couldn't do a bunch of kids
yeah really
it's like YouTube channels you do two
channels or you could hire people just
tell that story to [ __ ] kids in high
schools and the birth rate will go down
big-time Nicole Lee [ __ ] that sounds
terrible and flight sounds terrible I
still want to fight shut up a video of
it
[Music]
[Music]